you guys I guess it's time for another
live stream oh it's time kalila is
giving birth to a fun fun fun new thing
you're gonna have to wait and see what
I'm actually giving birth to on the live
show yes and it's gonna have a sleepover
slumber party drug experimentation theme
I'm calling it now and you can get
tickets at
moment.co.co trash Tuesday and it's all
happening Thursday November 17th at 7 pm
and guess what you know Esther how your
name is old yeah I got something
exciting for everyone there's an early
bird special
all right when tickets go on sale
there's an early bird special for the
first 24 hours when you get your tickets
boom and a live stream is on Thursday
November 17th at 7 pm Pacific and again
get your tickets right now at moment.com
trash Tuesday
look at I went to get a fake ass and
they gave me fake pies
and it's so distracting
um I did some sketches with them for my
solo podcast and I was shocked at how
trained people are to not look at your
fake tits and not me not me girl
the nipples are here
the views we lose from my nose we will
gain twice over from your teacher what
do you mean your nose
I hope the Latin teens on Tick Tock are
happy now I honestly cannot believe we
didn't get her in a bald Gap I mean
honestly this hurts so Esther you're I'm
Gru
because that's what teenagers on Tick
Tock have been calling me for the last
six months and I just want them to know
that you know what I can handle it and I
you're anti-semitic okay
you're anti-semitic yeah and you guys
think I have sex with dogs and that
makes you guys
anti-comedy not like jokes you're crazy
you choose bestiality over jokes my
nails are so like sharp that I stabbed a
hole the neck it looks like I got a
treat oh my God oh my God
are you about to beat us up
um no
we got gnarly Quinn over here you guys
Happy Halloween it is our Halloween
episode and Lila is dressed as Harley
Quinn
she's really pulling it off well we have
juicy Jeske Johnson in the house in the
kalila chair or should I say Harley
Quinn where is kalila I wanna I've never
met her I wanted to meet her I have not
met her either
she's not Steve no no no
[Laughter]
kalila is I don't know where's Kyla I
think this Bobby for the story I heard
through Carlos is that Bobby uh refused
to come back to do tiger belly and he
made everyone fly to him in Hawaii
can you imagine being that rich yeah
well again
I can better look at my new Wawa cup I
just love it Taylor bling baby it's so
pretty and sparkly I'm putting the
[ __ ] handle under this I'm having the
producers put the handle on this you
guys gotta get some Taylor bling baby I
love it she gave me my Wawa it's brand
new huh it's so good
so Annie what inspired your costume
let's talk about this I like to live
dreams out in my costumes you fail every
time I just want to tell you what Esther
does is her laziness comes out and bites
her every Halloween what were you last
year
I I raped or something no that was our
Thanksgiving episode when that was a big
problem with George Esther had a real
Square down the door shoulders were
squared she was ready to go he made us
look like food
um I you know a funny story I applied to
a Hooters in Champaign Illinois when I
was in college and what they couldn't
see you over the counter they did not
hire me
um what is this a did you always want to
be a Hooters waitress no I just was like
I always thought Hooters waitress is a
funny costume but you got to go all out
there's no
you can't hold back but I've been having
fun with these titties can I may I have
some fun yes you're gonna love them
they're better than you think
they're so good oh my God my God there's
a sit right there
come on titty [ __ ] me titty [ __ ] me no
you can bash them oh my God one of my
tooth popped out
[Laughter]
I'd be like my lawyer was here this is
my God what if Dave watches this episode
and he's like I think Annie should come
over for dinner
oopsie I spill a lot too these are
bigger than your boobs what yes I can
never tell on your stature they always
are you there are so they're 18 times
bigger than my boobs I got the biggest
ones you could get I can tell
it's an e e or maybe
as in come eat off of them Dave
[Laughter]
Todd loves them he's so happy with them
it's so disappointing I'm like Todd
you're supposed to play it off like this
is disgusting to you oh I'm into it too
I'm like
and now a word from our sponsor better
help easy and affordable online therapy
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better hllp.com trash Tuesday hi you
guys I am back on the road in December I
am going to be in Seattle Portland and
San Francisco and in January I'll be in
Phoenix get tickets at astronice.com and
check out my solo podcast my pleasure
available everywhere you listen to
podcasts
hi sluggies so excited for you to meet
my juggies
um I have been having the best time I
snuck on the Reddit I know I'm not
supposed to look at Reddit but I snuck
on the Reddit and I read the sweetest
little Thread about you guys at the meet
and greets and I love you back it's been
so special and so amazing and I like
it's like a drug to meet you so give me
my fix guys come to come see me in the
meet and greets you can see me
um in San Jose California with Juicy jet
ski Johnson
um 11 November 11th and 12th I'll be in
Michigan through December 1st through
December 3rd I'll be in Florida in
February and I have a lot more dates
we're adding right now so go to
annieleterman.com shows also every
Monday at 5 PM PST 8 P.M Eastern I have
my audio show don't bore me that's
interactive come tell me your stories
it's been absolutely wild and also Annie
wood is out and available go to
annieleterman.com I mean go to
animelderman.com but also go to Annie
Letterman on YouTube subscribe
um it's all over the place so thank you
guys so much foreign
I actually have been unrelated to
Halloween well could be related
uh I have my period and I'm just curious
a bloody mess
it was it was a Monday and okay um do
you can you pee with a tampon in and not
have to change the tamper yes sometimes
sometimes you pee them out yeah
don't doesn't the P like loosen it up
and then it's like never gonna really
work it's you're too old you're about to
not have your period anymore you're
wondering these like aquarium to tampons
I'm savoring the memories that you are
on your way out your height is not your
uterus let's just say your uterus looks
your age I think that you should be so I
would think so supportive of me
exploring the world of tampons but you
know I've been a pad girl ah I like pads
too you do oh I got two I'm surrounded
by pad girls I love it I'm not even the
pattern
it all over we I use it all diva cup
Tampa oh I'm all at the same time
but I switch it up depending because I'm
not gonna wear a diva cup to like a bar
because what I'm gonna like rinse it out
in the sink oh I know public battles
wait that's like the whole to me that's
the best part of a diva cup it's like a
public bathroom
they should be on stage and those people
are your audience oh God that's worse
it's like green rooms can you just
always have a bathroom please do not
make a [ __ ] and well and release our
Diva cups in front of our fans that is
really hard it's so bad and I've gone to
the men's bathroom okay so it's even
worse at the shows yeah why why do you
use the men's bathroom I like the glory
hole
I like a little peek I like wait I like
a little penis coming have you really
ever seen a glory hole I have seen a
glory hole but it was endless sex shop
it was in like a
uh like uh they had like an arcade where
you could watch porn in the back and
guys [ __ ] each other through the
or maybe there's a girl who knows maybe
that's like the excitement of a glory
hole you're like maybe it's a girl maybe
it's a girl I know Carlos has had some
[ __ ] experience Carlos is this the
time you really tell us
whoa I've been to the gorio ooh the Gory
Glory I legit didn't know glory holes
were for like gay guys
he does naively come out when they're
like oh I didn't realize that was that I
was gay the whole time and he's no we
haven't seen all day everyone listen
we support where you are in life and we
will be very comfortable with you
whenever you are comfortable to tell us
what you need to tell us to look at
thank you you're welcome he gets it yeah
I love this I mean look I think Carl's
honestly at this point will choose that
narrative over his other narrative that
he has going on around the internet
which is that he's the reason Bobby and
kalila broke up
hold on I gotta take this hello
oh wait this is real hello
hello I was spam risk I was gonna ask
them if they'd heard about Carlos and
kalila
they probably have what do you think
weigh-in
it's so awkward on bad friends oh you
gotta bring her back we're always
fighting yeah can I take this with me
you were my lawyer yesterday really I
didn't know when that would air but it
was still very awkward yeah this kind of
could be like a judge wig too yeah yeah
this is our generation's judges in the
future how did it go
um the trial went great I got Carlos uh
I'm not gonna say I got him off because
yeah yeah he's innocent yuck I'm
handsome he is an innocent man he's a it
was it was proven you don't think he's
innocent you're just mad you weren't the
lawyer
yeah or juice almost going crazy homo
her [ __ ]
the jiggliness of the handle that is so
funny I will say if I ever am in court
though I will come to you first thank
you oh my God you don't have to set up a
fake lawsuit is that so you can stand on
her shoulders and you guys will be
regular size that would be awesome wait
how tall are you five four oh she is
she's a a tall person the number one
question I get migrate it's not like
how'd you do it Annie or what's going on
with you or we love you it's always like
am I a small zester
is a liar she's shorter than you you
know I park cars at The Comedy Store a
lot and you're one of the only people
that I have to move the seat
um like back to reach the pedals you and
Brad Williams
that's funny because sometimes I do move
it back for people but sometimes I
forget but maybe even when you do that's
very possible when you move it back do
you ever feel your tampon getting pulled
out a little I know you're new to
tampons now speaking of what you said of
wanting to be asked how would you do it
at a meet and greet I had a similar
experience where I once went to my high
school theater class like I went back
after like I had had my show alone
together and I was like so excited to
talk to the teens no one had heard of
Hulu no one had heard of free form like
I know that's what you're trying to
pretend I was on Hulu
she's recreating history here actually
let's make her the writer because she's
very creative it's streamed on oh you
were the writer
like no kid gave a [ __ ] about me at all
and I was like wow this is not how I why
would I respect someone shorter than
them that's true at their age
I've got this tiny [ __ ] out of here
that's true
um I like yeah the funniest thing this
is a repeat but it's good enough I think
she was on tigerbelly and she and kalila
was like oh Bobby and I watch alone
together and she was like oh my God you
do and she goes no no the show Alone
Together
together it's like the greatest moment
of podcast history number one yeah I've
seen Alone Together you killed it in
that for real oh thanks you're already
on the show you're the uh no we love it
oh my God the only comedian who's ever
said that to me thank you that wasn't on
it otherwise like I liked the episode I
was in
Bobby was in it I don't think he he said
it listen Bobby's been a lot of things
he hasn't mentioned he's probably
shooting something right now he doesn't
want to mention
um wait so you guys went to a
renaissance fair today oh my God I wish
we should have brought our stuff I know
I thought about the little hat we went
it was really fun going on the road with
Annie I've been featuring I've just
started going on the road with people
been taking me and it's the first female
to take me and that was exciting for me
and uh yeah I didn't suck my dick or
anything yeah it was crazy I was like
come here suck my dick you want an extra
few minutes
Come Blow me [ __ ]
oh you know but I'm just kidding I am
just kidding I am just kidding actually
the people she got the right promise I'm
just kidding he's not unheard of it's
not it's not did you ever blow anyone
did you get Facebook let me think it's
not an instant no it's really it just
happens sometimes it happens after you
get the stage time it's you know you
can't help it you fall asleep with your
mouth open on the plane I mean when I
dated Tony he was hosting the open mics
but that's so sad
yeah the lowest level oh my God and we
hung out with oh my God okay wait do you
want a toe you tell them because you
hooked it up but I will I did not hook
it up with anyone she hooked up the
opportunity I blew jet ski I actually
thought that's his neck I was like yeah
it is
how they've been getting me to feed you
yes we've all been bagging her we've
been begging I love that reversal but so
um Esther's like is that true could that
really happen I could see you getting
people like doing a bidding board have
you open for them
wait yeah Marin won it I opened for him
somehow Marin won he blows me is that
how it works we'd watch I'm saying it
even Dave my watch
all right
um
okay so sorry I had to fix my neck
um okay so we go to Kansas City and now
I'm a big fan of the show The Challenge
like a big fan I need to just pause and
say that you would be hot with a broken
neck thank you so much
yeah there's something hot there do you
think it's because it's pushing my
double chin back
no it's no you don't have a double chin
you fish and you get it
it's just everything you dream of yeah
but so okay so
loved the challenge my friend Wes who I
found I found on uh
online we became friends we'd never met
in person but he and his wife live in
Kansas City so he's like I'm gonna come
to your shows and come to town so we
ended up going to their house all this
footage will be on Annie with my solo
podcast but um but we went to his
Mansion he's like [ __ ] Rich he put
all of his like winnings over the years
of this reality show he's been on it for
20 years who is this this guy Wes from
The Challenge and he no if you don't
know you don't know it's been on for
like 38. I didn't know something
it's like and he just wins it a lot yeah
but he just invested his money so now
he's just [ __ ] okay invited us there
he is there's our boy
but anyway so we went to um we went to
his house his mansion and we got IVs
yeah there was like a doctor there and
like they did this vitamin IVs and uh
found out I have tiny veins tiny veins
the woman was literally squeezing the
bag you know you'd have the same thing
yeah
we're such pygmy girls
like how hot is this by tiny veins so
tight yeah they're tight and wet tight
wet shriveled
I was like is it in yet
no yeah it was really fun and then we
went to the Renaissance Fair yeah we
only had about an hour before the show
and Annie did like the badass like Quick
Trip ever we went we got costumes
immediately I went to pay for him she's
like I got it nobody spends a dollar on
my weekend yeah for real I start opening
for you
I charge you all of a sudden I'm not I'm
the one not paying a dollar like you
misheard it
you're like pawning your wedding ring to
keep up with what you're doing
no yeah we bought and I've never bought
costumes I've never like leaned into the
Renaissance Fair because I was like is
this something you'd want to go to yes
and then invited us as a joke and I was
like whoa and Annie's like haha but then
she looked for me and she's like wait
would you really want to go and I was
like yeah my dad and my step mom got
married at their unfair she's a ren Fair
baby I like grew up at the fair I'd go
there every season sometimes on off
season because my their friends owned a
shop there and some people live there
even when you know regular folks start
going through they haven't like all
cities right it's all over and the one
in Arizona is the one I'm referring to
but I'm assuming because I was like
let's see Kansas City in medieval times
yes no Jesse made such a good point
about it it's like you go to the
different ones and you're like it's it's
true to what would be like in that town
it is it's that like accurate there's
some there's a lot of uh well who knows
I've never read a book so I don't know I
hate the history of anything Game of
Thrones is that medieval I feel like
they're mostly in like Europe the
medieval times and like the Renaissance
and everything but if it were
I don't know if the Native Americans
yeah I guess the time wise it wouldn't
have actually been in Kansas City but do
you know what I'm thinking can you read
my mind right now it's not related to
that can you read it
I don't you look like gross
is that what your mind was saying can
you believe it they were right look
because your head is round in a way
where like even though you have hair
yeah I can see what a bald cap would
look like on you yeah like your hairline
like illuminates it it's so cute yeah no
I the hot version obviously the the
teens on Tick Tock are smarter and more
evolved than all of us they see things
we can't see you know we were getting
treated like you're getting treated like
a like a um a substitute teacher what do
you mean you're you know how the kids
are the meanest and most brutal
substitute teachers they're just they're
giving you the substitute teacher where
it's like the meanest insults like they
don't know you they're not going to meet
you you're right you're in and out of
their lives you're as easy as a flip up
I can't believe this is the moment I
realize that I have substitute teacher
energy that is really dark but it is a
role I'm willing to take I don't think
legally I can substitute teach because
what have you done no because if you're
little I think you have to the One
requirement is a college degree
should I go back to college so that I
can be a substitute teacher at my high
school verbally because my kids on TV
yeah wait no I I want to go I think I
actually want to substitute teach me too
oh my God
the teacher that was in the news for
having big boobs like this
wait I want to wear those when I go
teach I won't wear them in the job
and now a word from our sponsor better
help Annie we are mentally not well
we're mentally not well there's a few
things I've added into my life that have
perked things up yeah but I see that but
these I can't stop temporary
okay they're not permanent I need help
up here
have you ever been stuck focusing on
problems and not Solutions last night
yeah do you know what's so crazy about
Todd too he just sleeps through the
night and I'm like do you not have the
wake up hiccups like I wake up like like
I just wake up with like a thing and I'm
like how am I thinking about this again
yeah I was up at 5am like just dripping
in sweat anxiety terrified about what
costume they were gonna get you
um but it can be tough to train your
brain to stay in problem solving mode
and that's why therapy and getting
actual help from someone
will change your life and also I feel
like I always have to give this
disclaimer like I every day wake up and
have to struggle to find peace like it
is not I'm not fair and that's not just
a piece of pie it is actually peace
peace World Peace no it is it's like
it's a choice to wake up every day and
take care of yourself and it is a choice
that I make and I do need help to do it
and it's most people aren't raised to
learn how to be solution focused like
that and that's not your fault it's not
your parents fault like it's just we
none of us have the tools and that's why
better help is so important and if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online I just feel like every
time I try to do something that's hard
and helps me it's like there's obstacles
in the way and better help cuts out so
many of those obstacles you just it's
right there for you it's so easy and
what's great which I wish this was
available to me when I was in my 20s you
can get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and you can
switch therapists at any time and when
you want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday for today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help.com trash Tuesday
[Music]
oh wait wait do you you seem like
someone that often gets mistaken for a
child as well a lot of people say we
look alike
but you don't you just have the same
childlike wonder I feel like you are
sort of if me and Annie had a baby
which we we will carry them to full term
either of us you know one struck out I
probably will
I don't know four tries
[Laughter]
oh my God yeah you you could be like our
little love child I could do that yeah I
know and people say I look young all the
time yeah I see that for sure it's your
your what did the wait what did the
security guard say Katie oh I love okay
we had the best security guard he's a
huge and I've we all felt so safe around
here oh he was the best he was like I
really kind of wanted to [ __ ] someone up
for you and we're like okay wait you
travel with a security guard no but I
have I will be soon yeah I'm just I'm
cusp cusp of travel she got recognized
at the ren Fair of course she did I was
like I wish we were here longer because
you know that's kind of my demo
it's like the record store The Ren Fair
anywhere where people collect things or
living in a specific time that no longer
exists I just want to they got a picture
with like a couple people got a picture
at the University flipping through their
album where it's like a suggested night
Annie Letterman oh my God our picture I
should have brought our picture we took
a picture we took a Medieval Picture
yeah we just we really went through it
fast we got the costumes we stopped at
this next shop but they take your
picture and you dress up and they're
like we'll get you in and out in 10
minutes yeah they did we all dressed up
and uh Todd was that Todd was the monk
you were the queen
give a little pink hat
wait what were you thinking when you
looked at me and asked if I could read
your mind just that I love it you look
like I was like I wonder if she can tell
that's what I'm thinking oh because when
you guys just mentioned pictures do you
know what I might be thinking a story
that we've probably told on this podcast
it's kind of not enough for you to
really know what it is give me one more
hand okay
um autographing pictures
oh we didn't tell that story I don't
know if we did but I think it's worth
telling okay tell her we went to
Montreal there were we can't say who the
comedians were no we're not but there
were these comedians that were like
I don't think we have these people
anymore in our lives we're not just like
I don't want to say Enemy of the State
but it was like they were
obnoxious they were like it was people
you know how it is when someone like
thinks they're really successful and
they think they're better than you yeah
like that's it everyone gets the vibe
from them they're like and I don't know
people like that anymore that was a very
like feelings like this like that was a
very like also that person followed me
on my birthday randomly and I was I
screen grabbed it I forgot to send it to
you like oh my God birthday wish it
finally came around to accepting that
you are talented enough to follow oh my
God I did did I follow back gotta wait
till their birthday I still got more at
my level what's that I think as you
ascend up and like you gain like like
you said like where when you did those
shows with the teens or people still
don't know who you are but you do gain
that respect from your peers and and
that feels really good yeah I'm still
like coming up so I get I get that and I
definitely remember it more like when I
was more in the open mic scene or
there's the levels are more up and down
right last thing about you though Jesse
and where you're at is like okay so
you're like blowing up I think we can
say you're blowing up you're doing great
but and people it's like a position
people want to be mad at you for right
like like there's hate that wants to
come at you jealousy competition but
you're really nice and a good person
positive energy so they they're they're
[ __ ] they're like duh where do I put
this energy maybe I'll have to work
harder maybe I'll just have to do my all
my life I'm having a weird open mind I'm
having a craving to see what it would
feel like it's a motorboat no if your
titties pressed against my vagina okay
come here oh my God what is the show I'm
on this is that's porn
[Laughter]
oh my Lord oh my God
oh my God I loved it got [ __ ] oh my
God are these Sleepover by Esther pants
yes they are so cute well now they're
group pants
why because your penis grew
we okay so tell her what happens okay so
we all like get off the plane in
Montreal and it's like fun we're there
it's the second time we're both there
right yeah it was really fun and we were
in a shuttle with a group of comedians
right and and
but things were kind of tense right like
two comedians clearly like didn't want
to like laugh and have fun with us which
by the way it's fine I've been in moods
where I'm like let them have fun and
they were traveling together anyway so
maybe they were in a fight or something
so it's like whatever so we get off the
plane
and so we're swarmed by what feels like
Canadian TMZ I mean at this point not us
no past yeah there's a group of people
with cameras and pictures and everything
just pushes past us and goes to them and
is like can we have your autograph and
pulls out these like headshots of them
and we are like we're like whoa
we're like where are these guys we're
just like oh wow like okay so they were
right we were wrong yeah like our big
stars we're nothing they're better than
us I see why they didn't want to talk to
us or make eye contact big thing in
Canada yeah like they're hot [ __ ] okay
we're nothing so we like basically we
look at each other we're like oh I mean
it was so like literally like shoved to
this we were felt like it was like
getting owned getting sent to the mail
room we were just so sure we were
actually better than them but we were
wrong we were completely wrong and then
moments later they like pivoted and they
were like oh my God we have pictures too
Annie Esther we were like okay oh thank
God because we were it was like it was
hard yeah so we're like never mind we're
good we're like okay
worst none of us matter yeah these
people just start making wasted
Investments yeah assign these but
actually not a bad investment now
that we have trash Tuesday
sign autographs of podcast Stars I think
you have to die for those to be valuable
right
yeah valuable yeah yeah by the time you
sign them too is is more valuable as you
right yeah well do you think your
autograph changes over time too maybe it
gets sloppier because you're not as like
excited about it yeah like maybe they
got like like the ends or really
pronounced well I know when I was in
elementary school I had the perfect copy
of Britney Spears's autograph you are
such a sick [ __ ] and now mine is just
sloppy and I don't care but I like
studied her writing and made it like her
did you have any autographs as a kid did
you collect just a Chris Farley one that
my dad got oh that's cool yeah he met
him at uh the East Bank club which was
like this fancy gym in Chicago that my
dad would sneak in it's so funny to meet
him at a gym I know yeah I agree weren't
expecting to meet him in I agree and
it's on the autograph is on the back of
the guest pass that my dad used because
he didn't pay to get it yeah because he
refused to pay yeah and my dad had such
a good scam going with this health club
because he said that I was like how did
you sneak in time and time again he's
like after you go so many times the
staff just thought I was a member so he
would just walk right in that's awesome
I know and that's like where Obama
played basketball and like Oprah Winfrey
it was like it was like a night Oprah
Winfrey also worked out for the one time
in her life damn this is like they
didn't decide some ndas that they went
to this gym it was like a 90s Chicago
scene for sure I love that your dad is
like kind of a [ __ ] like you did
well he's like I'm not gonna pay but I
will only go to the finest yeah yeah and
well he took me to see Tommy Boy so he
was so excited to see and we we like
grew up watching SNL obviously too yeah
I said we grew up me and my dad are
siblings we really are kind of yeah I
feel exactly the same way about my dad
do you really yeah I feel like he's yeah
he's like my best bud yeah we just like
laugh our [ __ ] asses off of my dad
but so okay did you ever have any
autographs or anything I had the Disney
book like you know all the Disney
characters but I didn't meet many famous
people in Arizona so it wasn't until
like shortly before I moved to LA I
worked at this coffee shop jobot coffee
it's awesome and I remember like Dimitri
Martin came in oh that's cool I couldn't
look them in the eye oh you didn't say
hi to him I like took his order but I
was like I've never seen a famous person
yeah and he still recognizable because
he has that like hair the like bowl cut
kind of yeah he's so cool he's so nice
and then the Flight of the Conchords
guys came in and I've seen them live
twice since like before I even started
stand up so I was really excited and I
happened to have my birthday card so he
signed my birthday oh so that was cool
and uh and yeah that's about it and then
I moved out here and a lot of
moving out here for me with stand up
getting my confidence up is being around
famous people and like realizing that's
everybody's just people yeah and like uh
you know and that's helped me in my
stand-up a lot be more confident and
yeah I thought that I had learned that
lesson and then I met Kendall Jenner and
but did Kendall Jenner meet you
definitely not that's a really good
clarification it was very one-sided not
steep did you have any um autographs I
had like my dad got me I actually had
Michael Jackson's autograph shut up yeah
my dad got it from he lost it doesn't
matter yeah but how did he get it well
my dad was working used to work at Penn
and they had a University of
Pennsylvania and they had a so weird
your dad had a good job he had a regular
job that's a great job no it's like but
like a like a person that is like
presentable and stuff I don't know he
like pulled it off though he like
couldn't believe it we all are like this
is insane Dad how did you do it he's
Charming yeah Charming his defense
mechanism as a child was to be Charming
so he got through it all but he and he
also was mentioned my dad's really smart
but 80d but so he um he was in a meeting
and they were making a college fund
there was this guy Michael Milken who
was a a huge con artist that got caught
I don't know in like a Ponzi type scheme
or something like that is your dad
surprised that his daughter has such big
knockers he hasn't seen that my mom I
have been bouncing around on FaceTime
with and my mom's like takes it like
almost as offensive because she also
doesn't have big boobs she's like wow
you're really having fun over there huh
pulling the nipples out and like
pinching them and like Todd will come up
and punch them
Randy's biting on it yeah
but my mom like my mom also is just like
I've been telling all my friends about
your boobs so like in person she's like
annoyed but then she's like proud she's
so proud like I told everyone to make
sure they watch your podcast let's see
your boobs and you've been going around
town and um I have so many more bits to
do in these boobs it's like so funny
that your boobs are big like I kind of
feel bad for a woman with the big boobs
because I'm just looking at them
laughing I know but yeah
[Applause]
the reaction was so much like people
were so respectful to the idea of giant
fake tits in this world no it does
command respect yes people are like
ma'am right this way women did like they
were like people were giving me a lot of
eye contact they were like
like they were not looking down they
were like we are gonna show our respect
I know aren't they so fun they're so
real wait so carry on about your your
she you have to stop she's losing it
help her just tear them
breastfeeded should I can't even speak
English anymore oh my gosh
wholesome [ __ ] cheese baby you should
have given that 11 year old this podcast
I'm like dead right now you need to
finish your story about your dad okay so
there was this con artist and Michael
Jackson came together to make a fund for
like a college fund so he said that
Michael Jackson was in the meeting
asleep the whole time he had a hat over
his head and then afterwards my dad was
like can you say to Annie Max and Timmy
love Michael Jackson and it was on a
paper my dad lost it but you know who
cares he you know that's the thought
that counts yeah thank you papa and then
I got embarrassingly
I got well it's not embarrassing that
thing's embarrassing being who you are
and where you are your time in in your
life I at 19 got backstage passes to the
my mom used to work at this radio
station 88.5 wxpn and I got backstage
passes to this like Fest and I got to
meet John Mayer Who I now have met
randomly a million times and I have not
been like I autographed when I was 19.
did he try to [ __ ] you when you were 19.
no I think I was too flat
look at you now though look at me no
dude
[Laughter]
it's just so fun like you are gonna just
see like web series of me just with
boobs this is the saddest wand ever
curls it was 14.99 why why are we
getting such cheap budgeting here that
feels expense
Spirit on Alvarado
there's a guy pooping outside of it
why do you bring us the guy pooping this
is for a kid Carlos I need an adult
sized wand
there were so many ones at the fair we
had there were so many wands there were
so many wooden swords can I have the
skull is that what you're getting
what are you doing what happened you
zooming in on your booze yeah you just
wanted to take a look this is pretending
everyone's weird now okay
so
your dad gets married to the Renaissance
Fair to my stepmom to your stepmom how
old were you yeah I think thanks I think
it was uh
childhood trauma yeah I can't remember
she's like it's so weird to like have to
like literally come with a wooden sword
to a wedding she's like I blacked it out
I must have been in in junior high so I
was like 12 30 were you into it are we
like I can't believe the Renaissance
Fair no I was into it like [ __ ] yeah
yeah and we dressed up like I was in
part of the it's called a hand fasting
ceremony and it was I thought it was
cool because I've been we'd go to the
rent for every year so and they tie
their behind their their hands together
oh my God my friend had a better wedding
that's so nerdy oh my God
Queen how does it work but I thought my
dad I still think my dad is like so cool
but it wasn't until I was later that I
realized other people don't think
medieval but that's Lord of the Rings
stuff is but that's but when you get
older that becomes cooler when you
realize other people thought it was
nerdy and people stood by yeah their
thing yeah it's like anyone that's still
playing Dungeons and Dragons like I
stand you know your kids the only thing
that's uncool is like judging that
because it's it's cool to just have
something you're passionate about like
if you like it what are you thinking
about in your head yeah
[Laughter]
more [ __ ] embarrassing [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] cool
it's cool to have interests okay I'll
just leave it at that I'm not gonna you
should see her when Jules comes on it's
so embarrassing she's like am I cool I
feel like I'm cool
Jill's like I guess I don't know what do
you need me to say but yeah so what made
you switch to tampons is the mushrooms
or no the drugs
um honestly I hate the feeling of a pad
yes the diaper like a diaper yeah but
now that I bloody Bush I like feel the
tampon like it's like I hate it I know
well I will like I have to admit on
stage quite often that my when my
tampon's half and half out yeah I was
like is she about to put that inside
herself uh-oh ratings pull it up what
what this is like a CBD Menthol thing
for cramps that I'm trying out you got
so much of the cream all over your pants
I've never seen anyone cream their pants
so like physically in front of everyone
look at how much you got on the pants
oh it's on the inside never mind oh yeah
it is we don't know did you shave your
happy trail no it's just like lighting
from the Sun maybe did you say it grew
out
later in the sun no sunbathing no no
what's going on with Esther she's
changing I just don't have that dark of
a happy trail because I've never shaved
it I've seen your happy trail more than
you've seen it okay I'm down there more
than you I gotta [ __ ] sift through
that mess that bloody mess peel the pad
off oh God wait I heard that you grew up
Wiccan is that true yeah can you use the
red Fair yeah on my dad's sign they're
the wiccans is that stuff I'd only be
half Wicked what does that mean can you
like are you scared why are you so
spooked out no I mean I'm intrigued I
want to be a doctor you want to hold
this while you're talking yes and can
you lower the lights
no it's hard to explain because it's not
like Christianity or Catholicism where
you there it's like the same church like
I guess it's kind of similar because I
guess every priest has a different take
on the Bible but the church isn't are
usually similar but um like we would
meet in a like a park or like the desert
and we would have
and and then it would be called the
circle and there would be a priest and a
priestess and it was just like a very
positive religion and it had a lot of
like a lot of Christianity which I was
raised on to my grandma's super
Christian as a they're kind of saying
similar things but Wiccan has a lot more
female
um presences uh like there is there's
it's led by a priest and a priestess
together and Esther's like I can't even
imagine them it's like uh and there's
it's all about the elements and nature
and is there witchcraft or not yes whoa
get to it put your [ __ ] nose on
you're scaring me
no I'm threatening our guests because I
I just you're a bully I don't love
religion like I'm like it's like a
little bit like but if there's like
spells and stuff yeah now you're into it
you were scared a second ago where's
that [ __ ] you're like are there
[ __ ] witches or what can I get my
high school ex to love me again or not
he doesn't want to love him back she
just wants him to love her we I was
always raised like we would do spell
work but I was always raised you should
be like careful what you wish for and
and specific like if you I was taught a
lesson all the time if you asked for
money be specific because you might go
outside and find a penny on the ground
and then your wish came true so it's
like you dumb [ __ ] you poor [ __ ]
but as I get older it makes sense
because you really I mean we you guys
know you have to know what you want to
get it and I feel like that's a lot of
life and and that's basically what spell
work is or praying really I think so
yeah you can get anything you want you
just have to know what it is you have to
believe it and see it
but we witches do you identify as a
witch no I'm I'm agnostic
I think I'm an agnostic Witch is that
something I think agnostic is like I uh
yeah you could be that what are you
thank you always write it up what are
you I mean I did get some moles removed
I've had witch like moles I was ready
the thing is I used to love like witch
witchery like Sabrina the teach which
was my favorite show and
um you know Ouija boards and all that
stuff what did I tell you that Caroline
and I had a great Caroline Ray and I had
a whole thing I've I've hung out with
her I love her she's she is such a fun
energy I love her so she should be on
this show 100 she is such a good she's
amazing she's so good I love her but I
then I met Dave and Dave is afraid of
witches so I had to really
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah he's
scared of witches so I had to like
really slower that side I had to dim
that shine a little and everything this
is what I love about Esther this is what
I love about Esther free Esther has
evolved so much since we began I
remember back in the day she was like
someone asked if she believed I think it
was like do you believe in God she goes
no I'm not a [ __ ] idiot now she's
like I'm a witch
Go sir a little iffy still I still don't
believe in ghosts though well I'm
telling you that's why people get
frogged if you believe in ghosts people
are going to be hiding in your attic
wearing your underwear so just make your
choice oh that's true my sister believes
in ghosts sorry bro okay frogging is a
new thing I've learned about that it's
my new is that I'm not afraid of it I'm
fascinated by it but so it's this new
like type of crime that can be committed
against you where it's a job opportunity
for someone like me and some people yeah
take it the attic is half full
um now
so and also she is used to being in the
Attic So
her people but anyway
I can't I can't it's her thing
um
I'm Jewish it's her thing it's her thing
she loves to get up in a creaky attic
and try to keep quiet but um just write
in her little book but um
so people will like be hiding in your
house they'll be living in your house
and when you're out they'll like go out
and stuff and they'll come down and kind
of eat your food and stuff oh like yeah
disgusting yeah I think so I never oh
yeah totally yeah yeah Parasite by the
way I'll never watch again
okay both times I just saw I I just saw
the greatest [ __ ] slasher movie of
all time terrifyer too I cannot
recommend it did you see it no I'm just
like it is so [ __ ] good I it's better
than the tits guys do you know what I
mean it's good
it's gory it's disgusting I was while I
was watching I was like to make Esther
come and see this would be like my goal
people are throwing up they're leaving
the theater what it's so disgusting it's
so no but it's so good wait that was fun
it's so is he gonna sell ice cream that
sounds fun no it's death and Gore and
everything's amazing did you see the
first one yeah the first one was great
too but this one's like insane it's so
good we saw it in theaters Todd and I
saw it it got it was limited release and
they extended it it's done better than
all of the high budget movies
like I think soci's movie did better but
Sophie's movie by the way also awesome
really smile it was so good but um so
then
um so then I'm doing this live about it
I'm like oh my God I want to be like
chopped in half like the first one they
chopped this girl like down by her [ __ ]
into two pieces oh my gosh and then this
one's worse like they get better you
know what I mean so it's just like
amazing so I'm like oh my God and Damon
Leones the the Creator right and I'm
like oh my God you guys tag him I want
to be like chopped up and then I go to
follow him he's already [ __ ]
following me dude he saw me on Rogan
that's awesome so watch terrifier three
[ __ ] okay especially if you think I'm
annoying and I interrupt a lot watch it
your dreams will come true
but it was so I just like love Gore I
just like
it's just you loved Al Gore so I love Al
Gore the inventor of the internet
I remember an SNL sketch there's like
there's too much Gore on TV and it was
just Al Gore you love climate change I
love I you guys there's one thing I love
climate change your pro climate change I
love I love I call you Annie weatherman
yes any weatherman
okay wait one thing that's scary that I
heard about climate change though is
that like it basically goes like people
are like oh it's not that bad it's not
that bad but that's like how it works
like it's a slow slow burn and then it's
like oh I'll be dead by that it's fine
you think that would be cool
or we're all burned together banana
banana bread
the thing about we burning together
sounds fun no we are codependent people
we'll be fine we have fomo as long as
that happens to all of us at the same
time we're good
but then like Elon will be in Mars and
he'll be fine I don't think we'll be
with them we know we're one degree
removed okay I'm one degree remember
from Kevin Bacon and Elon Musk [ __ ]
okay I'm doing just fine
we're gonna talk
you're killing it more than one percent
guys
follow us you guys like us we're the
ones that is yeah wait the one percent
I'm pretty sure doesn't ask for
followers by the way Elon Musk is like
please follow me the reason I was
considered because his
dad is the one percent you really
hammered down that banana
oh somebody makes me like
Nana's when I'm wearing this
you please wear them on stage at the
store I think I do have to see what it
would be like to have them on stage no
you have to nothing will compare to you
in person with Dave with those titties
nothing will compare he I don't how
about when I was just naked in front of
Dave
that was like our prank like just being
naked in front of Dave it's like a funny
prank Dave was inside the house on a
zoom writers we're just really real
important people and I had people that
like don't deal with our nonsense yeah
and I had Annie over and we were like
doing a try on of the sleepover by
Esther samples and so we were in the
yard to be like quiet and then Annie's
just strips down fully naked and it's
like teasing days it was like
Dave's just always trying to do the
right things yeah he doesn't like when
you and Whitney get naked in front of
him he gets like really scared he feels
like he's being like teased Whitney
feels like all the time whoa is that why
she's always showing them
I would bottom yeah yeah showing them
off
right why didn't you said bottom she
bought it
um
you told us we couldn't look at you like
because it was gonna be a reveal when
you came yeah thank you very much saying
that it sounded so bad you said we
couldn't look at you I'm like oh my God
I did I know I caught that no one you
were in the changing room but I could
see your ass sticking out oh it's so
good something was coming
what what exactly do you have on the
bottom it's supposed to be like a um
well you're supposed to have something
over it I had like the you know how the
Hooters waitresses have like the um kind
of shiny glossy Yes actually I do I got
them but I got everything for my size
forgetting that I was gonna be wearing
prosthetic things that's why this had to
get cut and that's why these are just
exposed because I couldn't the leggings
couldn't fit over the ass do we still
have Hooters around yeah and have you
been like at all what is it I did a
sketch I did a sketch of me going into
Hooters asking for a job and the manager
throwing me out it's Outpost it I'll
post on my story when this one comes out
the day this comes out but um I go in
and the manager put like I go can I get
a job and the manager is like you have
no tits and like throws me out and then
I'm like what I'm a good waitress and
then these guys come by they're like I I
you have no tip I bet you you're not
even a good waitress you titless [ __ ]
that's so funny I've seen it I've seen
all your sketches my can I shout out my
friend Jaime mirandas my first roommate
here and one day he was like dude you
should go on trash Tuesdays like he
loves that show and I was thinking yeah
and I thought at the time like I thought
at the time like oh yeah I'll just go do
that because I didn't know you guys so
you know it felt very Out Of Reach and
so it's cool to be here now hell yeah
[ __ ] whoa
whoa so cool now we and Justin are going
to do more stuff together we had so much
fun it was such a good time it was
really fun yeah also shout out to
Nehemiah from [ __ ] real world and the
challenge I've been watching The
Challenge now yes on Netflix yeah what a
good influence she's been on you it's
great it's a great show and it's all
about not quitting and going and and you
just you just commit and you can win but
these like the slice of My Life Is So
Exciting and featuring because like
Polly took me first who also tried to
start [ __ ] between me and I said that's
a joke remember he was like Esther's mad
at you
I'm like there's no way Esters about it
I don't think she knows who I am
not no bruh and then yeah like who has
Esther been mad at I start even before I
started Madden I just see her with them
yeah
I just see her with him all the time
like okay I guess that was fake I knew
the girl who cried Grudge
I knew who was kidding
um
and then and then Santino's taking me to
assault uh Salt Lake City and and that
was really fun Whitney will come for you
we're new on copy man Jeselnik now right
Justin like I'm I'm going on the road
with next week or this weekend next week
but it's just Irvine in Ontario so I
don't know I and I think the club set me
up with him
um but he must have approved it but
anyway it's different when like Annie's
and Santino and Polly are like flying me
out like that's different I'm so excited
to feature sorry Tony jez and Tony I
should mention Tony and clip too I
always forget him because it happened so
long ago but he did take me was killed
Tony he did take me actually he started
this whole thing to kill with kill Tony
um to Swansea and had a limo pick us up
from everyone in their place and then
get picked up in a limo and we went
through a McDonald's okay that sounds
fun McDonald's drive-through in a
limited it's also yeah
the whole menu but I have we're going to
San Jose it'll be after it'll be before
this one airs I think no no November
11th and 12th oh my God you guys come to
San Jose I'm planning some [ __ ]
special ships Josh Potter's gonna be
there I'm gonna [ __ ] spoil you guys
it's gonna be fun I just think like it
is fun to go on the road and it's fun to
like have good times in between the
shows and crazy things and I'm kind of
past the point in my life where I wanted
to
just relax in between shows I'm like
let's just [ __ ] party we lived it up
and someone in your meet and greet
because I was trying to help um Todd
like sell this stuff while they waited
to get a picture with you somebody said
I love what Annie's doing for you it's
nice to see her doing you know paying
back the things people did for her who
did what for me I know no but like Rogan
and Whitney I guess oh yeah yeah Whitney
like gave us but you and I never like
toured to open with I did no I had I had
I opened for Jim Norton back in the day
that's sick
um yeah no one used to take me out to
steak steak and stuff like that we went
to um Outback Steakhouse
did have lobster tail we had Lobster
that that's true I guess yeah I even I
opened for Rogan a couple times and that
was like that's so fun he still talks
about it he's like she killed she was
doing all these rape jokes I'm like
that's so funny I didn't think it was
like a former rape joke comedian I know
he's like I wish you'd get back to those
rape jokes
well I had to stop because one night I
was out to dinner with my dad and he was
literally so proud of me he was telling
the the waitress my rape jokes I was
like Dad like no no but yeah my parents
like he Joe was so nice to my parents
like they still talk about it like he
was so [ __ ] nice I know it's really I
was thinking Jim Gaffigan was like a
king to my parents when they came to New
York once it's like that means so much
yeah nice to your parents it really does
it's so good what do we got here
put on the hats yes by the way did we
have to get rid of a Harvey Weinstein to
get another focus focus
well I'm just saying it's like why did
it take 47 years we're like mine doesn't
fit my big head
it looks good
what is that I don't no no we're not
doing this cauldron that's just that's
poison it looks like an open huffit
[ __ ] you do drugs now
okay so what's this game will you
explain it in the news which is Brews no
you need to pick a name out of the
cauldron and predict the news story that
will happen to them since you guys are
witches can I just tell you literally
under 24 hours ago we were like can you
come with some games so this is pretty
impressive
wait does this mean that you stirring it
up
sorry I like
wait
should we explain it better yeah so make
a prediction here we go wait did Esther
come up with this no no here's the idea
make you're basically making a
prediction of the person that's on the
slip of paper it could happen tomorrow
or years from now but make your witch's
prediction
there's so many names in there
yeah like predict how they'll be in the
news in the next couple weeks or
whatever like oh my God I like Nick
Cannon you guys oh we pay we predicted
after we picked the name literally all I
saw was this and I was like uh oh I'm
about to get canceled
he just puts this look what the hell is
this I know I'm like
um
Van Dyke I mean he's gonna come back to
life and die again is he a dead or he's
alive how old is he pull him up it says
Dick Van Dyke I didn't no one knows what
it says I went like this
he's 96. he's 96. oh my God the age of
the queen and the age of Angela Lansbury
R.I.P going strong did he get the did he
get the witches so be careful don't kill
me we love Dick Van Dyke he was a brody
fan he came oh no he was I mean he does
he came to see Brodie Stevens at The
Improv one night and I'll never forget
that night because it was the day that I
discovered I first bought myself
highlighter like makeup and the only
person who noticed was Brody and he was
like Esther you're glowing oh my God
that's so funny he fell for it
we needed a [ __ ] medicated friend to
notice
um Dick Van Dyke is going to
be enjoying Brody's
no he's gonna live forever he's gonna
live forever guys he's gonna live
forever what do you want to say give me
the elderly person you picked it
ew you put it back
who was it that you put back it was a
trump I don't care about them
Ivanka Trump isn't she dead is she the
loving one
yeah
ivanka's the daughter oh okay yeah the
blonde I think she's gonna get big tits
she should okay I got Ben Affleck I'm
gonna say I see a divorce guy that's
pretty obvious
a fake a fake divorce for a fake wedding
I know how when she was singing to him
oh my God is she gonna sing at the
divorce oh my God okay uh
oh Mariah Carey oh I think she is going
to marry Ben Affleck
spooky that gives me Spanish together
Kevin Hart I think Kevin Hart is finally
going to meet someone that makes him
feel tall Esther
we're about to blow up [ __ ]
we I think that's a real thing that I
heard about which is short girl
privilege it's like we make people feel
tall so they like us if you see me in
pictures with my shorter friends I'm not
going to say their names but you know me
and her male I don't care about your
feelings
but men I I spread you'll see me do the
spread
um
yeah that is nice
you didn't have to oh Whitney Cummings I
predict a larger breast surgery I think
she needs to go bigger inspired by Annie
I predict she's going to be taking a
opener to the Renaissance Fair next time
look at this great idea I had Kris
Jenner oh
I have a feeling she's gonna continue to
advise her daughters to stay away from
Esther
she's gonna say no stay away from this
one this [ __ ] may be shorter than Kevin
Hart but she is not gonna get you where
you need to go
I got Pete Davidson oh I think he's
gonna start dating Kris Jenner or kalila
or kalila I think kalilah oh my God are
these just all people kalila's gonna
date
little nazex date kalila
oh my God
he's the only one that we're not
allowing today no that's the only one
that actually is going I almost had a
heart attack when I saw this why the
beginning I don't know Brendan Frazier
Brendan Fraser is going to win an Oscar
he is going to really I love him and
Encino Man too oh my god listen and
xenomen's my number one Paulie short
movie even though obviously biodome I
think I mean there's so many good ones
every probably short movie is good yes
but
um free Polly Shore movies not good
they're pretty good are you guys [ __ ]
serious I've actually never seen one oh
my God you know man you're so dumb you
didn't like biodome I did not like bio
you didn't like you will love Pauly
Shore Is Dead because you'll they'll see
a lot of people you know yours really
yeah for not liking biodome
I actually have a comment below comment
below is Carlos The Biggest Loser in the
world for trying to pretend he doesn't
like biodome he's playing antagon I
didn't like it yeah you got to watch it
wait what happened to this sleepover
someone wouldn't do the reach around
with you blame it on Paulie
and ask for reach-arounds when I was 13.
oh Britney Spears
um I predict she will get help
I like that
this one's too triggering
what is it someone you'll never ever
have
I predict that this person will be on my
solo podcast
this person's gonna be on my solo
podcast and love every second
Jada Pinkett Smith
uh is probably pegging Will Smith
in the future oh my God another future
boyfriend of kalila kalila's getting
around in the future
and Theo come on our [ __ ] show what's
wrong with you Jerry signed we want you
oh
Jerry Seinfeld what do we think for him
he's gonna come out with like an
underwear line now yeah sleep over by
Jerry
modeling like
like Calvin Klein underwear soon no
because they have Seinfeld 2 the movie
yeah this person is gonna follow Esther
on Instagram 100
ah
yay thank you I was special when she
quits she's gonna just devote her time
to not on Instagram on Tick Tock and
this person will not
Kylie Jenner
I know
oh no
what I think this person's gonna be on
my solo podcast because they hate Esther
my titties
Dave King For The Listener whoa oh my
God hold him right where he wants to be
Justin Timberlake what do you guys think
hot I hope he never posted Tick Tock
again because he got completely roasted
what did he do it was just like I guess
I'm on Tick Tock now it was so cute
like this
what this one means a lot
what is that
I don't know how to like excite I like
to collect people
I don't mean it in like a no I collect
people you're one of my Barbie dolls you
know that you're my Homer Simpson Barbie
I know I was like okay I'm the one with
the
extra weight on okay wait that's not
true no I know
we're gonna get her
it people people are gonna be like
you're delusional you're delusional I
just wanna let you know like 100 we're
gonna get her who is it
yeah
we are
Gaga
I saw you twice in one night at the
House of Blues in 2009 in Chicago
uh but listen to Annie actually we love
you queen I'm wearing your [ __ ]
makeup right now [ __ ]
yeah trash Tuesday for House of goggles
well should we do a Gaga spell yeah yes
oh give us the spray Aster we have to
Huff the spray
I was if I had had more time into this I
was definitely wanting to do something
where you have to put your hand in and
it's gooey oh my you're involved in
gooey touching you would really be a
good older sister to a little sister
that's what I think that might be what
our Dynamic is that we play out because
my older sister tortured me and you
would like someone like got away with it
you're so your boundaries are so tight
it's hard to even get in there that's
why it's like she caused why does those
sweet tight veins of your both of you oh
don't don't make every man horny
what's this
you know what it is you witch
for the second annual pumpkin drawing
what's this little thing that stands
before us which is what should we do
with him
we'll carve it
floppy oh yeah and then just one more
Kim Kardashian
what do we think
get back with Kanye
no what if Kim started dating Bobby and
Carlisle started eating Pete wait Kim
and Bobby is a vibe
another woman making a man feel tall
what is she five two I believe yeah
Courtney's my height Kim is an inch
taller than me in Courtney's your height
yeah isn't that insane that's crazy yeah
okay so I always have that all right to
draw each other
all right giggle [ __ ] let's go
I want to step on your nose but oh no
that's like uh World War II propaganda
yeah
Sarah Silverman's coming for you this is
your costume knows not your real nose
thank you but this is this is the main
attraction yeah as who oh oh you do
yourself I thought we were supposed to
draw all those oh wait let me add myself
to mine hold on it'll be real oh I
didn't know you I didn't know you drew
anything
I did oh yeah you're fast yeah
and he's just insane okay I'll go next
okay so here's Annie oh yep
there's juicy and there's me I love it
okay here's me it's just my tits with
Dave's name
here's juicy she's chilling just like
whoa I'm thinking about horses doesn't
it seem like she's always kind of
thinking about horses or something yeah
she does have that look she's like I
could ride a horse yeah later maybe
later yeah it's kind of chilling
relaxing like
she's kind of always relaxed a horse
fantasy and then
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] it says Esther with
her period leaking because she doesn't
know how to use a tampon
remember my Esther's her tight little
waist her big titties and her thank you
I love it
played the boobs in this that would be
awesome
you have all the boobs in hers too
they're all puppies
get demonetized thank you so much for
watching another Chaotic episode of
trash Tuesday and please tune in
especially chaotic when Kay is not here
well we do have a special announcement
about a possible host change yes guys so
stay tuned I think hopefully next week
you'll hear about that yeah and we can
kind of just put all this to rest and a
special thank you to jet ski Juicy Juicy
J no jet ski juicy tiny veins is the new
one yeah it's true Johnson thank you for
joining us and Annie come see us in Jose
in San Jose and Jose I don't even say
the sand anymore Carlos's nephew we
partied it was so fun we had such a good
time thank you for coming down the road
thanks for coming on the show Esther
you should consider opening for me
I've been treated yeah like a queen
you guys have a happy safe Halloween
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]